thank you
wait today's standing right
wait okay it's bring your daughter to
work dad he's like wait
literally you've got two biggest
I know it's beautiful
gorgeous thank you so much for having me
I'm such a huge fan I am such a huge fan
I don't know you're told to this I
literally was obsessed I asked to have
you on the show I love Vikings Valhalla
oh my God thank you so much I'm obsessed
with it too yeah have you seen it have
y'all met have you ever interviewed nice
to meet you I'm such a fan I'm with
Kelly too the stuff you do on that show
and these legs for days when she gets
out there is incredible and your nails
great nail game everything's happening
but I have to say that with this show
I'm like I loved it I saw the whole
first season I'm like do you ever get
hurt there's like big stunt Chiller
doing yeah I mean it's a very action
heavy show and even though I was first
you look like a superhero so yeah I mean
I was so fortunate that I got to do all
of my own stunts but with that you know
sometimes comes injury I've got a couple
of scars in my hands but there was one
time we were about to shoot we're doing
the last rehearsal I have this big
takedown it's a six foot seven big man
and I'm strangling him with my bracelet
and we're doing this big wrestle
takedown and of course I slit and he
lands on my elbow I get a fracture and I
have to go to the hospital wearing my
full costume
in the middle of that pandemic so no one
from production so I just show up at the
hospital looking like a viking looking
like a viking covered in blood in my
full armor and the people's hospitals
are like what is going on no one could
come with you no because of covet they
just dropped me off and they're like
we're gonna come and pick you up so I
just walk into the emergency room and
they're like what happened to her I
haven't seen this before yeah oh my God
hysterical
um so wait so you can you explain for
everybody that hasn't seen a viking zoha
like what's your character who's your
character who do you play so I play
fight this Eric's daughter who is one of
the most infamously bloodthirsty women
of the Viking era she is the sister of
Leif Ericsson that I'm sure people know
a little bit more about and yeah so we
are a continuation of the original show
Vikings and we're set 150 years after
and it's Chronicles the most famous
Vikings that ever lived so y'all do you
really deal study that like in like in
Sweden whenever your kid you study yeah
that's really cool I mean being like
Swedish you know Vikings so such a huge
part of our culture and so I was really
proud that I got to um you know
represent my Heritage and also funnily
enough my dad's name is Leif like my
brother in the show and my nickname
growing up was Freitas so oh my gosh to
yeah like a lot of happenstance yeah wow
that's crazy cool that your dad must
think this is the coolest thing now ever
so we've been talking about doing things
over ourselves this year in the new year
what do you instead of like a New Year's
resolution which is what are you going
to do for you this year oh my God that's
such a good question I recently got
married congratulations and
I didn't actually know that
congratulations thank you so much that's
so beautiful and I've been in Ireland
three years filming three seasons of
Vikings Valhalla so I'm just gonna spend
some more time with my family oh that's
exciting that's hard to do when you love
working and you're you know you love
your jobs that you're doing it is hard
to navigate that word there is no such
thing as balance that thing is balance
we'll go ahead and be your wise older
team
I love that I love it though I love the
old shooting Ireland too I love Ireland
it's so beautiful and the people and the
music it was so unfortunate because we
filmed during the pandemic so we weren't
able to experience going you know to the
pub and listening to oh my God the pubs
you've never met a stranger everyone's
so nice and you're never alone yeah
which is a good thing you know you're
always going to find a friend but
finally in the towards the end of
filming season three that we just
wrapped a couple of weeks ago we were
able to go out and you know experience
Ireland which is so wonderful oh it's
beautiful
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]